-Guys, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
This is very exciting.
From the number-1 movie in the
country, "Don't Worry Darling,"
Nick Kroll is here tonight!
-Oh!
-On our show!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Don't Worry Darling."
Nick is going to tell us
what it was like to star
in a crazy drama and also how it
was like being in the movie.
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, with all the
holiday travel being planned,
President Biden has proposed
new rules that would require
airlines to show consumers the
actual price of plane tickets,
including baggage fees and other
extra costs, before they buy.
Yeah. Of course, the airlines
all responded by adding an
"able to see the full cost" fee.
But besides that --
Yeah, airlines will have to show
all their hidden fees.
Right now, every
credit-card company is like,
"Don't make eye contact.
Don't make eye contact.
He's walking right by.
Don't look at him."
Of course, out of spite, now the
airlines are being too honest.
Today, pilots were like,
"Well, folks,
this turbulence is
something to worry about."
Listen to this.
A new poll found that,
in a potential 2024 matchup,
Biden and Trump
are essentially tied.
Keep in mind the poll
has a 3-point margin of error
and a 10-point margin of
"These guys are like 80,
let's not get ahead
of ourselves."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, everybody is
talking about this.
Rihanna just announced
that she is headlining
the 2023 Super Bowl
halftime show!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Rihanna!
But it's Rihanna,
so she was like, "Wow.
This is one of the
top-10 honors of my week."
You can tell fans
are excited because at
the beginning of every game,
the announcer is like,
"And remember,
the winning team advances to
the Rihanna concert."
And it was just announced
that Apple Music
has replaced
Pepsi as the sponsor of
the Super Bowl halftime show.
And just like with Pepsi,
the NFL was told,
"We don't have Spotify.
Is Apple Music okay?"
Of course, if it rains, Rihanna
will stand under...an umbrella.
♪♪
Or she'll have to be submerged
in a bowl of rice for two days.
Since it's Apple.
That's the way Apple...
During -- Speaking of the NFL,
during yesterday's game --
I don't know if you saw this --
between the Miami Dolphins
and the Buffalo Bills,
Miami's punter
had his kick blocked
in a pretty unfortunate way.
Watch this.
-I don't know. This is risky.
And it was blocked.
-Oh, my goodness!
Blocked, indeed.
Let's see if we can get a...
Oh, it hit the personal
protector, Sherfield.
-Ooh, yeah.
The refs ruled it a safety
but said it was
very close to a sack.
-Oh! Whoa!
-Very close.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Well, hey, everyone,
this is very interesting.
I saw that a school in Australia
banned a student for having
an inappropriate mullet.
Good thing we don't have
any rules like that here at
"The tonight Show,"
right, Higgins?
-Right on, brother!
Can't lock down these locks.
Bottom up, homey.
-I hear that, brother.
The administrators
at that school
need to take
a chill pill, brother.
-If I went to that school and
they tried to tame my mullet,
you know what I'd tell them?
-What?
-I'd tell them this, brother.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Rock 'n' roll, brother.
Hot damn, brother!
-Come on! Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I heard that grocery prices
are skyrocketing due to
a nationwide butter shortage.
-Ooh!
-It's bad.
At CVS, they moved
the Land O'Lakes
behind a locked display case.
I'll be honest.
Biden might have
survived the gas crisis,
but there's no way in hell
he's going to make it through
a butter shortage.
No way.
And, finally, guys,
it's the beginning of the week,
and I thought it would be nice
to kick off things
with a few words
of encouragement.
It's time for some
"Monday Motivations."
Here we go.
-♪ "Monday Motivations" ♪
[ Peaceful music playing ]
-When you met Taylor Swift,
that was the best day of
her life, too.
Your therapist
thinks you're hilarious.
Go ahead, post the photo
where only you look good.
Your friends will understand.
When deodorant gets
bought by you, it's like,
"Yes, this will be super-easy."
That spider you just killed?
He wanted to die.
It was his time.
Your high-school crush realized
they were in love with you
the day after graduation.
And, finally, you know what?
Spell restaurant
however you want.
Everyone knows what you mean --
the place with food.